Hi and welcome to Udacity's machine
learning engineer nanodegree program.
My name is David Joyner.
I'm a course developer with Udacity,
as well as an instructor
over at Georgia Tech.
And I'm thrilled to bring you this
program because machine learning is
really at the core of many innovations
going on in lots of different areas.
Finance, education, healthcare.
These are all industries that are being
revolutionized every day by what
machine learning can do.
And in this nanodegree program, you're
going to develop your own understanding
of what machine learning can do for
these areas as well.
Over the course of this program
you're going to be covering the major
schools of thought in machine learning.
You're going to be using the same tools,
the same methods, the same
algorithms that experts are using
everyday to uncover new information
about different industries.
By the end of this program, you'll have
developed a portfolio that demonstrates
what you can do,
the kinds of problems you can address,.
Including some problems
we've picked out for you,
as well as some problems you'll
get to pick out for yourself.
I'm excited to get started,
and I hope you are too.